[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Applaudissements] [Musique] [Musique]
donc [
Musique]
donc
[Musique]
nous pensons que les masques et les gants sont
susceptibles de
constituer une menace pour la faune marine
[Musique]
les gants sont enlevés sont probablement
confus par des animaux comme les tortues de mer comme
nourriture comme les méduses qui sont leur principale
nourriture
[Musique]
l'intégralité du réseau trophique est
essentiellement en danger ici
parce que lorsque ces plastiques se décomposent
dans l'environnement comme tous les plastiques
qui décomposent l'environnement,
ils forment plus petits et  des particules plus petites
et ces particules
peuvent alors avoir un impact sur la quasi-totalité
du réseau trophique,
des plus petits animaux aux plus grands
[Musique] [Musique
] [
Musique]
[Musique]
vous